Dr. Zakin, my name is Duned from India
but living in Kuwait. I completed master
degree in microbiology.
My first question is is it halal to
accept sales commission? What is the
Islamic view of acquiring the sales
commission by an employee for each
business which is done between one
company and a customer? The employee may
be acting as the mediator through a
phone call or even without that. Some
people even ask for big commission just
for a phone call. Regarding the question
asked that is taking sales commission
permitted or if a employer gives to the
employee a particular thing to sell and
if he says that if you sell you get a
commission is it permitted? There are
two types of sales commission that if
you take a sales commission and the
sales commission is given from the
profit margin of the employer it's
permitted or there is a MRP of that good
and suppose the MRP of that good is $100
and the employer tells you $100 is a
good you sell from that $100 I'll give
you $5 or I'll give you $10, 5% or 10%
whatever it is it's permitted but if the
cost is $100 and he says that you get me
a client and I'll sell it for $110 then
it's not permitted because you're adding
on that commission to the purchaser. So
if the commission is added to the
purchaser it becomes prohibited but if
it's not added to the purchaser then
it's permitted. Here there's a thin
line. What you have to understand that
what is the MRP is the maximum retail
price of that cost. And there are many
times when the owners of the shop tell
architects, okay, get a customer to my
shop, I'll give you 10% commission. Now,
if that architect or if that agent gets
a customer to the shop and if the
commission is given in such a way that
no extra cost is there on the sale price
of the goods, then the commission is
permitted. Like you get customer what
you purchase, I'll give you 5%. No
problem. as long as the retail price of
the goods he has sold to the customer is
the same and from his profit he's giving
you 5% 10% is permitted oh you get a
client who is rich I will increase the
cost from 100 to 150 I'll give you 25
that's haram the cost is 100 why you
increasing to 150 and then giving 25 or
I'm increasing from 100 to 110 and
giving you 10 that's not permitted so as
long as the cost is not added extra to
the customer then the commission is
permitted but if the cost is added the
commission cost is added to the customer
then it's not permitted. So this type of
commission is permitted but adding is
different regarding business. If you are
an owner, if you're buying a good for
100, then selling for 110 120 because
you're a businessman. You're buying it
now. You become the owner, then you're
taking a profit. You can take 10%
profit, 20%. I'm buying from wholesale.
I'm selling a that's permitted. That's
not commission. That is business. You're
getting a profit. But commission means
you don't own the product and you are
selling it. So the owner tells, "Okay,
this is the price. I'm not going to
increase the price. you sell, I'll give
you commission permitted. Or if or if
you're an agent that gets someone to the
shop and the owner tells you, okay, I'll
give you 5% of what he buys or 10% of
what he buys. As long as he doesn't
increase the the cost of the goods or
doesn't put it onto the billing of the
customer, this type of commission is
permitted. If he puts it onto the bill
of the customer, he charges customer
extra, then it's not permitted. Hope
that answers the question.